- I know there's a lot
of bumping and grinding.
There's a lot of like...
- It's like--
- Really, what?
(upbeat music)
- I'm Danella Dutton.
I've been teaching dance and
Bachata for about 10 years now
and I am here today to
show some brand new people
how to dance Bachata.
Bachata is my favorite.
It's a lot more intimate
and close and it's meant
to be sensual with the person
who you're dancing with.
(scandalized gasps)
- Don't drop me, Kenny.
- I'm not gonna drop you.
- Kenny's gonna drop me.
- I'm not gonna drop her.
- Okay, so we're gonna start
with some simple stuff.
We're all gonna go to the left
and you're gonna start
with your left foot, okay?
You're gonna go side, together, side.
You're gonna kind of raise
your hip just a little bit.
You wanna straighten out your leg.
We're gonna do the same
thing going this way now.
We're gonna go right,
together, and the hip comes up.
Side, together, oh!
- I used to dance as a kid,
like, when I was really little
and then I quit because I
was afraid it was too girly,
but as an adult, I realize
that being able to dance is
one of the sexiest things
someone can know how to do.
- [Danella] I want
everyone to take their ribs
and go to the left a little bit.
Kind of like you're stretching.
You're gonna go to the right,
you're gonna go to the left.
- I'm cramping already.
- Kenny, get up.
- Left, right, left. There we go.
We're gonna turn to the left, okay?
So, what we're going
to do is we're gonna go
all the way around, hip.
- It was fun. It was good.
I have never been to a Latin
club, so I definitely wanna go.
- I'm a little bit scared
of all the grinding
that comes later.
- [Danella] Right, left, right, left.
Your arms, don't let them hang like this.
You don't wanna look like this.
None of this. Keep your wrists
down, elbows coming out.
Let them hang like you had
two sleeves on your arms.
- I think we nailed it. (laughs)
- We had the passion
that everybody else made
up for with their technical skills,
but they didn't have
the spirit of Bachata.
- Michelle and Kenny are falling in love
and I don't know what's happening.
(laughs)
- I'm trying! I'm putting it out there.
- [Danella] We're gonna
be really supportive
of each other, but everybody's
gonna go one pair at a time.
All right? You guys are ready for this.
You're totally ready for this.
(Latin music)
- I loved Bachata.
- It was really fun.
I have realized that this
is the one use for obliques
in practical life.
- [Girl with White Flower]
Yeah, it was just enough sexy.
- It was not as sexy as I thought.
I think you need just the
right environment. I think.
- Yeah, he needs a drink.
- I think we did a pretty good job.
- I think we did a great job.
- I got to know Candace
a whole lot better,
so that was wonderful.
- I got to dance with a person
named Elvis, so that's cool.
- [Kenny] I would do it again for sure.
Only if Michelle's my partner though.
- Aw.
- Ready, two, go, turn,
left, right. Left, go.